Every organization
or enterprise or institution that offers
transformational programs, not all of
them, but most of them fall short is
sustained behavior change, living a not
having a transformational experience,
but living a transformed life. I I say I
didn't I didn't know this then. And I
know this after I left Landmark, but
there's three pillars like the pillars
here, the tripod. One is you have to
have a desire. You have to see there's
another way of being and you want to
live that way. You have to have
practices or activities or actions that
you do because that's what helps rewire
the brain. Having one experience doesn't
rewire the brain. It has to be
repetition. So you have to have
practices. And then given you and I are
humans and we're creatures of habit,
most people don't sustain those new
practices because they've got years of
old practices. So you need to create an
environment that supports you taking
those new practices over and over again.
And without that, there is no living the
experience. There's remembering it but
not living it.
[Music]
Alan, it's so good to have you here.
Thank you. Thank you so much for joining
me. I'm glad I'm here. This is such a
special episode for me. Yeah. Uh I've
done to this point well over,200
episodes. Wow. Yeah. H this is one of
the most special ones. Oh, thank you.
Yeah, maybe the most special, but
definitely one of the most special ones.
Good. Good. You know, and I just hope
that, you know, it's we love each other
and enjoy each other. So, I know it's
going to be special for us, you know,
but we're doing this so that it impacts
others, right? And that's one thing we
share in common, right? Living a life of
impact. That's right. Yeah. In fact, the
our journey together started out of that
mission. Totally. That was the reason we
got introduced to each other. Yes. And
this is what we've been up to. Yep. Two
years. Two years. Yeah. It's been a lot.
And it's been very consistent. Yeah. Two
years. Yeah. Uh so, you know, two years
in in my journey feels like a lot. Yeah.
And it is, you know, given your age,
right?
and and through one of the most growing,
challenging, yeah, incredible periods of
my life. Yeah. You know, Michael, when
you when you and I had our first call
and I said, "Well, why would you want to
have a coach?" It still is moving to me.
And and you said, "I just want to be the
best leader I can be." Very few people
have said that to me in 40 years of
coaching people. I want to be the best
lead. Well, I want to fix this. I want
to handle this. I want to get this. I
want to double my income. I want to, you
know, have more sex. Whatever they want.
I want to have less fights. I want to be
able to manage people better. You know,
all those are fine. But when someone
says, "I want to be the best leader I
can be," that awakens something in me.
Yeah. To bring out the best in me. You
know, and there are times when it was
tough. There's times when I pushed
sometimes harder than you wanted me to
push. There's times when I questioned
and wasn't pushing, it was challenging,
you know, and um unlike
most people, you kept coming back,
you know, it's been a very special
experience for me. We're only getting
started, so we have a lot of work ahead
of us. I know. I know. And we're up to
big things. I know. We're up to a lot of
impact, the two of us.
And I'm incredibly thankful for not not
just for the service you've been giving
me, but for the friendship, for the
mentorship, Yeah. for the inspiration.
Yeah. Of getting the privilege to watch
somebody that's up to living a life of
purpose, very intentional life, and
being so wholeheartedly committed to it.
Yeah. It's in the bigger picture of what
your purpose is. Yeah. And I'm really
excited to dive into that. So, I'm not
going to spoil the sentence yet. Good.
Um, but it's also in the small things,
in the small missions, and and I
constantly find similarities. Yeah. I
watched you 20 minutes ago sharing with
uh some of my team members your most
recent challenge and accomplishment,
right? And I was just thinking to
myself, "Wow, that's exactly what I'm
doing with my friends, you know, when I
accomplished something." Yeah. And so
it's very special. Yeah. Um and I'd like
you to help me unravel a little bit how
we got here. Not for me. Yeah. Yeah. But
in your own journey because today to
date you've worked with many different
types of people, many ex from the
executive level and you've had a
tremendous impact on so many people. But
I'm really curious about how you got to
the stage where this is what you want to
do. Good. From the beginning. Oh, yeah.
Yeah. So, you know, I had a really
challenging
u childhood. I was unpopular. I was
I tell people and I'll tell you and
anybody listening, you know, I there was
a little trajectory. It was started off
in the early years as smart pants, you
know, and then I got a little older and
it was smart alec. And then by high
school it was smartass and that was my
trajectory and it was I didn't know it
at the time but it was all a defense. It
was a strategy. There was something I
had to prove I was smarter than
everybody. Why? Cuz I was shorter. I
wasn't good in sports. I was picked on
sometimes because of my religion. And um
I didn't have good so I didn't have good
social skills and didn't play well with
others. You know, I couldn't wait till I
was old enough to go out with girls
because I'd already spoiled it with all
the guys. And I thought, I get a doover.
I get a doover. And it was interesting
cuz I got along better with girls than I
did with guys. And I remember being in
college and having my first deep male
friend. And that took precedence over
everything else. Being able to be with
Eddie sir took precedence you know uh it
was it was amazing I went good I know
how to have a friend and so that's where
it was and then you know I started I was
product of the 60s you know so I was
doing drugs and protesting the war in
Vietnam and went to Woodstock and you
know probably around 19 after some drug
trip I had I said my life I mean it just
like talk thinking to myself, my life is
going to be about impacting the quality
of life for others and it was a vow I
made to myself. I didn't use the word
vow but I said that's what my life is
about. So how do you do that? So first I
thought I'd become a teacher and then I
thought how few teachers actually
impacted me. I went the educational
system isn't designed nec at least the
public educate to have teachers make a
great impact. There are some that do but
I went nah. And then I went oh just hang
out in playgrounds and talk to kids and
then I'll make an impact. And I went
well men hanging out in playgrounds
talking to kids. Mothers say stay away
from that guy. He's a weirdo. So I said
that's not going to work. So I started
um uh in the senior year. I thought the
way to make I was at MIT and I thought
in the senior year the way to make an
impact was to have people eat good food.
So me and a bunch of other folks in the
senior started a vegetarian cooperative
restaurant in Boston, the Route One
Cafe. And we thought we were going to
change the world. Yeah. Well, it was
became pretty clear that just eating
good food doesn't change the world. It
got us access to concerts and, you know,
we because we would barter with any good
group that came to town and wanted to
have good food. We'd get to see their
concerts and we'd barter like that. But
I learned then that's when I started to
learn is how to have a group work
together because we were run as a co-op
cooperative. But I was on a spiritual
path. I I knew I needed to attain more
and um I lived in a Zen monastery right
after college as one does. Yeah. And
then I thought, you know, after 6 weeks
there I realized um
America is not going to become Buddhist.
This is 1972.
So was born Jewish, left the monastery
and um went back to the restaurant and I
went I met this mystical Christian group
and I went, "Wow, Americans Christian.
I'll join this group and become a
teacher." Mhm. So I became an instructor
in this mystical Christian group
teaching people how to create using
their words, the power of prayer, how to
manifest things, you know, before there
was the secret and all that stuff. We
was a little bit ahead of my times.
Yeah. And then in 1976, I did a human
potential training called the S
training. And in that training I went ah
there's no special rituals you have to
do. There's no beliefs. You don't have
to dress a particular way. You don't
have to hold your hands. And you can
have this transformational experience.
And that was and it was profound more
profound than any drug trip I had ever
gone on. What made it so profound? um
the way it was the integrity with the
way it was conducted. But at the la the
last day, I don't think I ever told you
this, Michael. The last day of that
training, December 1976, I'm sitting in
the Jack Tar Hotel in San Francisco. the
training's over and the way it would end
is you would sit opposite someone who
had done the training
already and they were there volunteering
and they had three index cards with the
names of three people they knew and they
would tell you the names of three people
and you'd say okay Barbara and they'd
say hold up the card with Barbara they'd
look at it and the guy or the gal would
say tell me about Barbara Does Barbara
have pets? What does Barbara do for
profession? What type of music would she
like? And the person had all the answers
filled out on their card. And I start
describing Barbara to a tea.
And I thought he's pulling my leg. And
he shows me the card and I went, "Whoa."
How do you explain that? Well, my belief
is we're all connected.
We're all connected.
And our egos get in the way of us
experiencing that connection.
But we can tune into things. And I went
and I had already known that, believe
that. But I never had that direct
experience.
And then he says, "Okay, you want me to
go through another name?" I said, "No,
I'm I'm quitting while I'm ahead." And I
walked out of that train. It was like
3:00 in the morning and I'm floating cuz
who wa this is something I've read about
yogis do whatever and you know so that
was powerful that was profound and for
me that's the kind of the window
dressing but what really
was made available in that training is I
could see the way I was designed
I could see the way I wound up and I
could step outside of it. So I walked
into that training knowing I was 26 and
a half knowing I was one of the smartest
people on the planet. Mhm. And I walked
out knowing I was simply one of the most
arrogant people on the planet. And that
was lifealtering
to see my own arrogance. Now everyone
around me knew I was arrogant except me.
I just thought they were jealous.
And I started behaving differently. I
completed with my father who I blamed
for why I wound up the way I did. So it
was lifealtering and I went good. I want
to make a difference with my life. I'm
going to lead the s training. Wow. So
that was 76.
In 1982 I went on staff with the
organization and in 1985 the sraining
became the land the forum. In 1991 it
became the landmark forum and I worked
there for 32 years.
Yeah. rose to the top as a design helped
design programs lead programs train
people you know how we're in Israel now
I you know opened up Landmark in Israel
with a few wonderful human beings in 90
and um left that company in 2014
and since then I've been coaching
consulting training designing my
programs and um here we are. Incredible.
And I don't know if that directly
answered your question because I talked
too long. We met about
I guess 2 years after I got a chance to
take part in the forum. Yeah. Um many of
the contents of which obviously you
helped design No, I didn't help design
the forum. Well, the I guess the con the
broader context of of the of the
program. Yeah, I delivered it. Great.
and I trained people to deliver it but I
didn't design it. Great. Thanks for the
clarification. Yeah. Um it was very
powerful. Yeah. It was a very powerful
experience. Uh I
experienced within 3 days. Yeah. Um and
uh having a friend give me a tip that
you know I should come into it prepared
to you know to to be present to
acknowledge what's there and to be
active on the court. I experienced in a
short amount of time what what's
possible for a transformation to take
place. I also experience that that
transformation can be short-lived.
Right. Yeah. And and you know I think
that's where almost every organization
or enterprise or institution that offers
transformational programs not all of
them but most of them fall short is
sustained behavior change right living a
not having a transformational experience
but living a transformed life. I I say I
didn't I didn't know this then. I know
this after I left Landmark, but there's
three pillars like the pillars here, the
tripod. One is you have to have a
desire. You have to see there's another
way of being and you want to live that
way. You have to have practices or
activities or actions that you do cuz
that's what helps rewire the brain.
Having one experience doesn't rewire the
brain. M has to be repetition. So you
have to have practices. And then given
you and I are humans and we're creatures
of habit. Most people don't sustain
those new practices cuz they've got
years of old practices. So you need to
create an environment that supports you
taking those new practices over and over
again. And without that there is no
living the experience. There's
remembering it but not living it. So,
help me unravel a little bit. Yeah. What
does it take to have that sustained
that sustained projection, that
sustained transformation? One of the
things that you told me, I think in the
first session we had was that you deeply
believe that every human is capable of
changing. Yes. No person wound up the
way that they are. Well, no person is
stuck being the way they wound up.
Perfect. Exactly. No. Why? Well, you
know, neuroplasticity. As long as you
can create new neuropathways, you can
have new ways of being and acting. Mhm.
Yeah. Well, you have people saying,
"Can't teach an old dog new tricks." I
know. It's just not true. People say
that to justify why they're not
changing.
Let's unravel that a little bit because
they're resigned about it. Let's unravel
that a little bit because I think this
was a really big deal. Yeah. I think
this concept of change and this concept
of the ability to adapt to be different
to wake up and say, you know what, I
know I know that, you know, I felt stuck
the way I wound up. Yeah. But I'm
actually going to be I'm going to
evolve. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, let's look
at a simple thing that we talked about
earlier where you heard me talking to
some of your colleagues. Yeah. Right.
From the time I was 42, I'll be 75 in
April, but the time I was 42,
I had a a story, a narrative, a wish, a
disappointment that my stomach was
bigger than I wanted it to be. H
now I knew what to do
to lose weight. Everybody knows what to
do to lose weight. I knew what to do to
gain muscle. And I would make
half-hearted attempts. You know, I do
some things sometimes and then not
others. Why? I didn't have an
environment that supported me making
those changes. Right? Knew what to do.
had some question whether I had the
desire because people say well if they
wanted to they would have done it and I
don't believe that there's a lot of
people who desire to have things happen
and they don't know these two principles
of they need practices and an
environment both
you know Buddha discovered this long
before our time he one of the noble
truths is he he takes refuge in the sana
sa means community. Without a community,
you're not going to live it. That's
creating an environment, right? Yeah.
It's an interesting concept, I think,
that on one hand, we give a lot of power
and agency to humans. Yes. And on the
other hand, we say, but there are but
there are limitations and there are
things that we should do in our
environment to help us. Yes. Because we
we are we will trip. We will fail. Yeah.
And and I think you know I'm looking
back I used to work with Danelli
behavioral economist and one of the
things that if there's one thing that
I'll take away from a year of being with
him is that we are we are irrational
creatures and the best way to help
enforce an action or a behavior is to
create an environment that fosters it.
Yeah. I can want to be on a diet but if
I'll put cake in my fridge I am more
likely to eat it than not. Yeah. I mean
although I don't like this analogy. I
mean you know what what's the motto of
the US Marine Corps? We we take so and
so and turn them into men. They have
practices
and an environment and it's structured
and there's no way out and if you don't
follow it they kick you out. Period. Now
most people aren't willing to live that
way. Why?
Why? Well, we want things comfortable.
Yeah. We want things easy. We I think
there's a phrase, I don't know if it's
accurate, an infantile will to power. I
want it. I should have it. So, we think
wanting it and wanting it badly is all
that it takes.
No. It's an essential part, but if you
want it, you don't have the practices
that are going to be expressive of it
and the environment to support you,
you'll be you'll die wanting with
regrets. I I am com I I you and I what's
predictable is we both will die. And I
know we're both committed to dying
without regrets.
And the only way to die without regrets
is to live without regrets. Right? So in
each moment don't listen to the excuses
you know when there's a gap between how
we want to be and how uh we are put
something in place.
But but that's why come I'm here with
you. You know it's possible to be a
better leader
and you've been around enough folks who
are not good leaders.
uh and you live with someone who is a is
a raised by someone who's a great
leader, right? So, it's it's not
genetics isn't going to make it happen.
None of that's going to make it happen.
Practices and an environment period. So,
I wanted to have a flat stomach signed
up for this program that, you know, six
weeks of a nutrition plan, a coach and
practices. Mhm.
And a Facebook group.
to communicate with regularly. Send
pictures of what you're eating. Send
pictures of your stomach. You know, I
lost 16 lbs. I'm lighter today than I've
been in the last 33
35 years. And now the question is, am I
going to keep those practices going?
Mhm. Now that the 6 weeks is over. And I
believe I am right now. you when you
started this out. Yeah. You shared with
me you had a note on your a sticky note.
That's right. On your lap on your
laptop. Yes. My body is a reflection of
my intentions. Now I started that a year
ago
and I said a year ago when I put that on
I had a thing on my wall, a goal by May
I'll be able to bench press this much
weight May 2025 and we'll live. But I
wasn't doing anything about it other
than sporadically. Mhm. Sporadically.
And then slipping. And now here it is.
We're not even at May yet. Incredible.
Yeah. Just amazing. There's nothing
special about me. So if I can do it at
my age, that means any human being can
do it cuz I spent 32 years not doing it.
You know, we're pretty good at the
things we don't need to do
when we're not as good as someone said a
a coach is someone I think it was one of
the football uh coaches. I don't know if
it was Mike Ditka, but u he he said a
coach gets people to do what they know
they need to do but don't want to do.
Yeah. Yeah. And you know, we we got to
spend some time together over the last
couple of days here in Israel. Yeah,
there's a lot of things, a lot of
decisions you have to make in the
dayto-day that need to be aligned with
this challenge that you're on. Totally.
And and the way that we like to do
things, we like to do things hard and
sometimes extreme. So, it's no surprise
to me that we're on the same diet even
and even though it's an extreme one and
then I'm here and I haven't had falafel
and I haven't had hummus. Give me a
break. Yeah. Who comes to Israel and
doesn't have falafel and hummus?
Exactly. And um well actually I did I I
falafel and pa hummus is okay. A little
bit of hummus is fine. A little bit has
some carbs. Exactly. Now in those micro
decisions. Yes. Cuz I the dayto-day
there's rarely huge decisions we have to
make that are life-changing. They do
happen. But that's right.
You know that our days are made up of a
lot of micro decisions where in each one
it's very easy to make the to to take
the comfortable choice to take the pea
to take the h to to not go to the gym
right now to yell at the person who's
disappointing you. Great. To curse the
guy who cut you off on the highway. Yes.
Those moments. Yes. Where you can take
one of two paths. Yes. And there's the
comfortable path of yelling and the
eating and not and delaying. Yeah. And
then there's the harder path which is
aligned with the long-term vision of how
we want to be in the world and how we
want to look and how we want to feel.
Yeah. What's happening in that moment?
Yeah. And what's the power that you
think we have access to here? Yeah. You
know, I don't know that there's any
power. Um,
one way to look at life, this is the way
Victor Frankle looked at life, is
there's between stimulus
and response, there's a choice.
Now, how do you slow things down enough
that you can see that place to make a
choice? Because most of us are very good
at after missing the choice looking back
and going I should have or I could have
or it would have been better if I
didn't. So that's where mindfulness and
presence and a some sort of practice
where you're present. You know what you
what's that say? You have to go slow to
go fast. M you want to really live a
great life, you've got to slow things
down. So you recognize there are choices
you're making moment by moment by moment
by moment by moment by moment. And
sometimes your pattern is making the
choices, not you most of the time. Thank
you. Yeah. And you know there's
if you look at it like it's a a growth
trajectory.
You know we start off with a desire with
some practices with an environment. We
get competent
at slowing things down
and then maybe we get advanced competent
at making better choices. So it's a
muscle. Yeah. Yeah. It's a pract and
then there's mastery.
So, you know, I've been at it since
for 52 53 years. You know, people and I
know this word is poo pooed, spiritual
practice, but it's it's practice.
You practice it and you practice it. And
what I've noticed about people along the
way, the moment you stop practicing,
it's gone.
it's gone, you know. So, I've got this
commitment to be to live true to my
purpose till I take my last breath.
And since I never know when I'm taking
my last breath, that means right now I
have to be practicing right now.
Is it getting easier over time? Yes.
because you're you're get getting those
neural pathways established of one being
present.
Uh, two, what I think what makes it
easier is having screwed up so bad and
not, you know, you learn if you're on a
growth trajectory, you learn from your
successes what to repeat and from your
failures what to you have to put in
place so you don't keep making the same
mistake over and over again. Yeah. So, I
I'm at that place in my life where
mostly I'm making new mistakes
and I've been we we got we weren't
allowed to work over the last two years
on the way that I react and the
different things that are happening in
my head in different circumstances. And
I and I assume there there's
similarities between a lot of people,
but they're also different based on a
lot of our history and how and and the
brain patterns we formed.
I've been fascinated to uncover for
myself, you know, how I operate and what
my patterns are. Yeah. And I've felt a
significant difference over the last two
years and helping distinguish Yeah. more
and more of these moments. Yeah. Of
having that between the what is it
between the stimulus and the response
and the response. Yeah. And
distinguishing that choice. Yeah. And
and it's quite an amazing feeling of
power. And the reason I said the word
power before Yeah. It feels it feels
powerful to have stopped that immediate
reaction totally and then to make a
decision. Now sometimes I still make the
wrong decision and I choose to go the
comfortable route but but having that
second to to ask okay how do I want to
be right now? Yeah. And yeah, and you
know, I just had an insight uh you know,
cuz people are saying, "Oh, wow. Did you
do this program because you're so vain
and you want to look better, you know,
for with your stomach and all of that."
And I realized in listening to you that
it it was an absence of integrity
for me to keep thinking about wanting to
lose weight and saying I was going and
not doing anything about it. And who the
heck am I to coach people to produce
changes in their lives and talk about
the structures and the environment and
then not do it myself. M you know there
are plenty of coaches out there that
don't necessarily walk the talk and and
I am not interested in well I'm
interested in them because they're human
beings but that's not the game for me.
You know I don't want to coach anybody
in anything that is theoretical. If I'm
not living it I shouldn't be talking
about it. And that was a lack of
integrity on my part because I would
coach people on what they should do to
lose weight and all that and I wasn't
doing it myself. M. Yeah. Interesting.
Yeah. So, I think that was a motivator
for me more than the getting the $200
deposit back or whatever. The motivator
was to walk my talk. So, a huge part
over our work together has been that
distinguish. Before you say that, can I
refer to one other thing you said? So a
a big sign of the growth you've taken
and that one takes is you don't talk
about yourself like this is the way I
am. The words you use and I didn't tell
you to use those words. The words you've
is I saw this pattern of mine.
Now who's seeing the pattern?
A pattern can't see a pattern. Right.
Right. So there's this leader in you
that is growing and developing and
manifesting who's seeing the patterns
that are inconsistent with being a
leader.
And you don't say, "Well, Michael's this
way." No, Michael has a pattern. That's
such a more use powerful way to look at
behavior is no, I've got a pattern.
Good. Create a new pattern.
Yes.
I love it. No, and a big part and that's
what you're doing. A big a big outcome
of our engagement and our communication
and talking is is I I I firmly believe
that I am operating for Michael in the
future. Yeah. Totally. And and I have a
vision of what that Michael is going to
behave and what his patterns will be.
And I'm sure that vision will change.
But right now I feel like I'm an
ambassador. Yeah. that's in the present
helping guide Michael towards the
Michael of the future. I love it. And uh
I love it. You know, and I love that
analogy because I don't think I've ever
used it with you, but I used to tell
people, Michael, that um you know, I am
an ambassador of the future and I am
welcoming people into a future that they
don't even know exists yet. Amazing.
Yeah. Yeah. Amazing. Yeah. And of
course, I I am very present to the
present. It's not just living in the
future, but it's a I I it it helps be
much less it it I I get to be harder on
harder on on the the briefing that I do.
Yes. Over my patterns without being hard
on myself. That's right. That's very
good. Yeah. You Yeah. Um cuz a lot of
people keep saying don't be hard on
yourself. Yeah. And I feel like it
misses. It's too simplistic. It It is
too simp. You want to be hard just not
on yourself but on on the pattern,
right? Yeah. Well, you want to be
committed to something. Yeah. It's a
commitment. You have a commitment. Uh
and you know, it's an interesting word
future.
You know, cuz people think time is
linear.
That's the way Westerners view time. You
know, Native American cultures view time
as circular. M
other folks view time in different ways.
So if you view time as linear, you know,
the past is behind us, you know, and the
future is in front of us and here we are
in between the two. And you know,
there's another notion that it's all
happening right now. Mhm. There's a
future that you are living into. Mhm.
There's a future that you're an
expression of. You know, like with my
calling, my purpose is all hearts are
full. All beings are enlightened. That's
not a someday maybe I'm going to get
there.
No, that's right now. I am committed to
that future happening now. Now, are
there gaps? Yes. Are there
discrepancies? Yes. That's what makes
that's why we're alive is to fill the
either ignore the gap or fill the gap.
How long have you had that purpose? That
purpose worded that way was um seven
years, maybe eight years. I think when
it first when I first created it, I
didn't call it a purpose. I I was 64
and I said I'm starting the third act,
you know, my my because of the Beatles
song. Exactly. And because I was leaving
Landmark. There you go. So I said
there's and because maybe you know 96 is
a good age. So I said, "What's going to
be my what what's going to be my third
act?" And I named the I said I want a
theme. I didn't call it a purpose, a
theme. And I said the theme is all
people are living lives of possibility
and all conflicts are resolved through
communication. That's what that was the
first name it had. And then two years
later, one of my colleagues said,
"That's goddamn complicated, Allan. Why
don't you simplify it?" And I went,
"What would it look okay? All hearts are
full."
And then I was doing a 10-day silent
meditation retreat, listening to some
discourse about Buddhism, and I went,
"Oh, all hearts are full. All beings are
enlightened." And it's been that way.
And it feels like
it feels like that's been my purpose my
whole life. Yeah. You know, and mostly
the first 22 years were living
inconsistent with it and paying no
attention to it and not even having
access to my heart. Yeah, it was all up
here. One of the things that we get to
talk as well about is being able to
reflect back on the past mistakes. Yes.
Um
things that may happen in the future
that we are afraid of. Yes. And living
with them. Yeah. And having them be
present. Yeah. And
when we talk about it Yeah. It feels to
me and when I get to practice it on
myself, I experience a s a sense of
strength. Yeah. In that experience. Yes.
Yeah. Tell me a little bit about what
does it mean to be with this the fear
the the past. Yeah. That's so good.
You know the word is presence being
present.
You know, most people are focused on
where they want to get to, but they're
not present where they are right now.
You know, I was walking down the streets
to get here
uh from the place where I'm staying. The
number of people that are doing two
other things while they're walking on
their iPhone, they're not in the
present.
They're not present.
Full stop. Mhm. Present to what? Present
to what's happening around them. Present
to their fears, present to their dreams,
present to all of it. And be in the
present. And I don't know the word. I
was going to say own it. I like your
word. Accept it. Be with it. Grant being
to it. You know, when you're when you're
Have you ever been with someone and
you're talking to them and you get
they're all there? Yes. They are
present. I get that with you all the
time. Thank you. And then there's other
people and you where are you? Hey, I'm
I'm here. Yeah. And they're somewhere
else. That's a discipline that I like
that word. That's a discipline to
practice being present cuz what happens
when you practice being present? There's
space.
You can see things.
New things can emerge. You know, some
people have to go away in nature to
create that or be in a body of water.
Yes, there's environments that sometimes
support some people in being you can see
a lot of distracted people, you know, at
the um at the sea, right? But there are
people who go to nature to be present.
Yeah. I I want us to be able to be
present in the midst of the chaos.
You know, we're the eye of the storm.
There's wind blowing around us. There's
rain. There's unwanted influences. And
we can be with it.
Anything. This is a little I think I
heard this first at landmark. Maybe not.
Anything you can't be with is going to
run you.
So if you have fears of failing,
what's going to drive you all the time
is your fear of failing. You won't
perform as well when you're driven by
fear.
You can run faster for a little while,
but when you're driven by fear, your
your body makes cortisol. Your your body
makes chemicals that shorten your life,
make it harder to be compassionate,
may make you run faster, weaken your
immune system.
When you're pres you dopamine response,
serotonin response, your brain makes all
you your body makes all sorts of other
chemicals when you're just being right
here, right now. M now this isn't about
ignoring your fears but it's about
expanding to yes I have fear right now
I have fear right now is different than
fear is running me sure I have my fear
my fear doesn't have me sure so I have
fears
that that's healthy that means we're
alive right
there's a there's a community of
entrepreneurs. Yes. That turns out to be
much bigger than I think most people
realize. Especially of founders and
CEOs. Yes. Who operate extremely
assertively
fast. Yes. You know, very they seem to
be, you know, on their game
and and they're driven by fear. Yeah,
that's right. I get to have a lot of
these conversations. uh especially with
younger entrepreneurs, especially with
first- time entrepreneurs uh and and I
think it's easy to mix up the adrenaline
and the experience of of of running
through fear because it it has
stimulations that mimic a lot of the
experience that you would get from the
dopamine, right? Being excited. Yeah,
totally. And and you see you see a lot
of them burn out. Yes. quit or drive the
company to the to the bottom or annoy
the people who are working with them.
Sure. Yeah. Sure. And uh we have we have
a couple of examples of that that are
getting a lot of popularity these days.
Sure. Sure. Sure. And I think it's a big
um it's a really interesting
um concept and exercise to to have that
distinction because in our line of work,
in my line of work, there's a lot of
things to be fearful of. We talk about
them and we talk about them a lot.
That's right. I'm very thankful I have a
community of of adviserss and investors
who openly work with me. Yes. In
unraveling them. Yes. And I f and I find
that the more I dive into them and the
more I talk about them and stipulate
around them Yeah. the more things expand
and they open up. Beautiful. And it's
quite special. That's great. One of the
things Alan that we have been speaking
about Yes. Um you know we've having
worked together for almost two years
now. Y uh we we go there's we notice
periods and one of the things that
you've taught me is that it's sometimes
helpful to distinguish a period in one's
life. Yes. Yes. That's longer than a
moment and longer than a project. That's
right. And there is a power to naming
it. Yes. Yeah. Understanding it. Yes.
And expanding to a new period. Yeah. And
you call that an era. Yeah. Yeah. You
know, let me give credit where credit's
due. I worked for a while with an
amazing woman named Carrie Granger.
Carrie Granger was an officer in the Air
Force was and um taught leadership in
the Air Force Academy and designed a
leadership program and then uh created
uh the Granger Network and it's now
called TGN. Mhm. And when I met her, she
was doing this work that she had named
error work. I I had been doing similar
work but not the same. Uh and
you know there was the era before we
could talk.
You know there's the era before we could
walk. We've we've lived through
different eras and in each era certain
things are possible and certain things
aren't possible.
So we came up with she came up with and
I've come up with a way of looking at
teams,
organizations and individuals and
couples. You're we're all in an error.
You know, there's the error when we were
passionately in love with each other,
and there's ways we acted in that era.
There's the error when we couldn't stand
each other. There's the error where we
were wondering whether we were going to
get a divorce. There's the, you know,
there's different errors. Yeah. So,
we believe you can consciously end an
error
and start a new one.
You don't have to wait for the error to
pass. You don't have to be observer
of the error that you're in. You can
consciously end an error and create a
new one. So it's taking this concept of
stuck. Yes. And we're not stuck. But but
this is a in in a lot of things at the
same time. Yes. Because because it's
hard to to stipulate. Well, can I really
change this era, live a different life?
Yeah. So, you know, everyone alive is in
an era, right? You know, there's ways
they're looking at life, there's ways
they're operating, there's moods that
are prevalent, there's accomplishments
that they have, and there's uh failures
that they have. We're all in an era. So,
the question becomes, is it possible to
end one era now because you're committed
to it and create a new one? And going
back to what we talked about and what
you talked about, you have to be able to
see the error. You have to the phrase is
name it to tame it. What are the ways
I've been up acting? What are the moods?
What are the things I've been avoiding?
What are the things I continuously say
to myself?
Yeah. How am I seeing other people?
All of that. That's an error. And you
can get it displayed on a wall. Takes
about a day. You can do I've done it
with a group of 80 people and I've done
it with individuals and it takes about a
day.
Then you
go sleep on it. Something happens when
you sleep on things. Come back the next
day. Name the era and then turn your
body and say that was then. What's this
new era? Yeah. How long is it? Two
years, five years till the rest of my
life, right? What am I going to
accomplish in this new era? What new
strategies am I going to use? What ways
of being am I going to practice? So you
name and then you name that. You have to
name it to tame it and you have to name
it to claim it. Right? But now and then
that's when real the real coaching
begins. coaching the player or the team
or the organization for how do they
consistently
do those new practices?
Notice like you said earlier when the
old the old practices are still there,
the pathways are there. How do they
interrupt it quickly? Right. Yeah. Get
that get those moments of choice and
practice getting competent at spending
more time in the new era than the old
era. Right. And this is uh
printed this out. Yes, I saw that. Yep.
And so here we uh you know one of the
things that was really interesting for
me is getting a chance to hear to to
talk together about this concept of okay
how do we how do I become better at at
being present to these strategies my
ways of being and being able to to get
those moments of choice and asking okay
am I now going to be in this old era or
the new era and how do I create neurop
plasticity and how do I
train myself right to be there. Yeah.
And so we distinguished um a bunch of
different ways of being and acting and
acting you know there from you know ways
with you know family and business and
finance and health and and different
strategies and we distinguished what
does it mean you know how would it look
like in the old era and how would it
look like in the new era. Yeah. And now
every once in a while I get to score
them. Yeah, exactly. And and Michael,
you know, when I first started this, I
you know,
you know, I'm I'm going for the gold in
terms of living true to my purpose. Oh,
yeah. You know, and
you know, when an athlete practices,
you know, every practice, they don't
just go to practice because they're
supposed to go to practice. Yeah. They
go to practice to practice something.
I'm gonna work on throwing. I'm gonna
work on,
you know, evasive moves, whatever
they're going to work on. Yeah. Um, and
if we don't take it ourselves, like
we're training for the Olympics and it
takes daily practice, you know, there's
things they don't eat, there's things
they don't do.
If they do them, sometimes they get
thrown off the team. Mhm. Why? Because
you won't get to mastery ignoring
certain principles, right? Yeah. So,
we're not designed to master things.
We're designed to survive. So, mastery
takes an environment
that will support you doing those
practices. So, I used to do it, you
know, uh every day track things. Wow.
For was I living consistent? And then um
you know I
we have time to tell a short story of
course it took place here and it in in
the Sinai desert in 1997
and I remember it like it was yesterday.
I flown there used to be a little
airport in north Tel Aviv. I took the
little prop plane and flew down to the
to a lot and then went with a friend and
we went to uh Taba and then there's a
bunch of folks on the Egyptian
side of the border uh having old cars
bedawind and they barter with you haggle
with you to get you to go with them and
you drive down through the desert and I
spent it was the Sinai desert in one
day. So we spent a day by by the um Red
Sea. They the better were fishing and
giving us fish. We're playing back and
at the end of the day
we had to find a driver to take us back
to
Taba and then go through the border then
to a lot take the plane back to Tel
Aviv. It was one day we're driving with
this driver halfway there. It's
beautiful. The sun is setting over the
desert.
The Red Sea is on my right and the
driver stops the car right in the middle
of the road and gets out his prayer mat
and starts praying by the side of the
car while we're sitting in the back
seat. And he comes back in the car and I
said to my friend who spoke Arabic, I
said, "Ask him what was like that was
like for him cuz I I was surprised." And
he said, "Oh, it was very important." I
said, "Ask him why." He said, ' Ever
since you got in the car, I I've been
thinking I didn't charge you enough
money. I'm going to have to drive back
empty. I'm going to miss having dinner
with my wives and my children.
This was a big mistake.
The moment I sat on the mat, I all of
that disappeared and I realized I was
doing the will of Allah.
Now, he said, "If I didn't do that five
times a day, I'd be a crazy person." And
that's where I first realized if we
really are going to be present, you have
to have practices throughout the day,
not just meditating in the morning or
meditating in the evening, but reminders
throughout the day. Are you being
present? What are you living consistent
with now? Are you being true to your
purpose? you know, so I put, you know, I
didn't get a prayer mat, but I put five
reminders in my Outlook calendar that
had bells that went off throughout the
day. And one of them said, "What are you
paying attention to now, Alan?" Another
just said, "Are you present?" Another
said, "What's your focus to remind me?"
So, I'd be there'd be bells going off
throughout the day. And that's was when
I first in earnest got committed to
living consistent with a purpose 24/7,
not just on the good days. Yeah. And
that's 28 years ago. Wow. And I'm going
to die play still playing that game with
the intention to live consistent with my
purpose. Period. And I'm going to coach
people in how they can do that. And
organizations in so many organizations
have mission statements.
The number of organizations that live
consistent with the mission or use the
mission to make decisions is so small
compared to the numbers who have spent
tens of thousands of dollars coming up
with mission statements. I think today
we see the companies that are making the
headlines in the day today. Yes. They
are companies that were some of them
were founded 20 years ago and they have
very clear mission statements. Very
clear. Organize the world's information
and make it accessible. Yeah. Connect
the world. Right. I mean these ideas
that are behind and these companies
today are doing something that's vastly
different than what they were doing 20
years ago or 5 years ago or 10 and the
world is changing. Yeah. But they're
sticking true but and I think the big
power here is that they're sticking true
to that mission. I I was at Microsoft
last week when working for two days with
uh some coaches and about 100 people.
their their mission is something like
create the tools that has every human
being be more effective, something like
that. And they're still there were
different things they were creating 30
years ago than what they're creating
now, but they still are true to that
mission. They were a little slow getting
into AI, but they're all in now. And
that's an amazing power. Yeah. I'm going
back to the to this the five reminders
and and we and one of the big things
that that we're going through here in
this conversation I feel is this idea
that on one hand humans are remarkable.
Yes. And we have endless and we have the
potential to do so many things that we
that many people maybe don't think
they're capable of doing. And it takes
something to do that. Yes. And even when
it takes something to do that, we need
to create practices to help us stay
there. Yes. Because that we're limited
and there's or maybe limited is not the
right word, but we are we have hardwired
patterns. We have hardwired. That's very
well said. And uh and I think that that
that living with these two things at the
same time is quite amazing. We have the
we have we have the possibility and the
potential. Yeah, it's going to take
something and nothing guarantees that
that we will behave that way. And that's
why we need to create an environment
that helps us stay true to it. Yeah. And
and that's why to make it to keep it
from getting too significant cuz that
could get very pretty heavy. Oh my god.
I call this a game. Yeah. It's a game.
That's the game of life. And you get to
create what game you're going to play.
The game I'm playing is live true to my
purpose and help as many other people
and groups and teams and organizations
live identify their purpose and live
true to it. That's a game. Sometimes I
win, sometimes I lose. Always I'm
learning. Always I'm learning. But
sometimes I win. If and you know, you
shouldn't play a game if you're not
willing to lose.
Yeah. Yeah. One of the
thing one of the things I found very
powerful in my life was maybe 10 years
ago I came across I was working on
gamification that was still back with
Danelli and and I discovered this
open-source
application website called Habitica and
Habitica has the name Habit in it is a
roleplayer play player type game it's an
RPG game where I have an avatar and I
get to to write habits that I want to
enforce. Oh, and behaviors that I want
to get rid of. Yes. And tasks. Yes. And
I get to assign a level of difficulty
for each one. Good. And when I do a
habit that I want to enforce, I get
points. Yeah. Good. When I do a habit
that I don't want, I lose health. Lose
health. I lose health. Yeah. So my my
character has health. Yeah. Got If I
lose too much health, I I go down a
level. If I get enough points, I go up a
level. This is great. And I remember
that it it I some of the most some of
the longest habits that I had Yeah. I
got to alter. Yeah. For a very long time
until today. Yeah. Because I was playing
this game. And so it's a very powerful
strategy. It's really good. You know, I
don't you and I have talked about taking
that uh display that you created, you
know, and if if we could gify Sure. what
it is to live consistent with your first
to complete an era, right? Second to
create a new one. Third is to get
reliable at living in the new one and
turn it into a game rather than it's
therapy or it's coaching. But it's a
game. Sure. and we can give you access
to play in the game and the structures
to win the game. And it's about there's
Yeah. This it's significant work and it
takes something you know I was in I was
at Portland, Oregon. That's right. Being
with the old era that it takes something
to and I you know yesterday I met with a
friend and we read through it together.
Oh and it was a great experience for me.
It was interesting for him. I don't know
how interesting. Maybe I forced him to
read. I don't know. But but one of the
things he told me was, "Wow, this this
is this was must have been really hard
to do." Yeah. And I thought to myself,
"Wow, yeah, that took something." And
and the more I realized that it took
something, the more the prouder I was of
this work. Yeah. And I'm sure that we
could even go deeper than we did. But
what I then love about this is that we
then made it into a game. Yeah. And then
it becomes light. And it's not about
drowning in it and constantly thinking
about it. It's about Yeah. Yeah. This is
what it is. And it was and I just spent
24, 48, 36 hours, you know, doing this.
And now I get to to play with it. It's
great. I remember one of the first
people I did this with was a professor
of um dermatology
at the University of Wisconsin. He flew
out to Portland and we spent a day
distinguishing his old era. The next day
when he showed up to create the new era,
he said, "I shared this with my wife
last night and she was amazed." He says,
"Is that man a psychologist? What? How
did you do that?" And he went, "No, he's
not a you know, it's just it's not hard
if you have the right environment and
the willingness. It's not hard to
distinguish an error. That's 1% of the
game, right? 99% is the practice of
living true. Right. One of the most uh
interesting graphics Yep. that I
remember from our work. Oh yeah. The
bridge
when we did the error work with your
team, right? Yeah. So what what does
this bridge symbolize? Yeah. So this
bridge was there was the old era on one
side and the new era. And after we
completed creating the new era, I said,
"Where do you think you are in the
bridge and you know, you're like one
foot Yeah. off the old era?" Cuz the new
era, the the bridge is the practice. And
I think the reason why this was uh in
such an interesting moment for me was
that there's this sense of pride and
excitement. Yes. That once we've named
the old era and we've generated what
could be the new era, there's a sense of
I'm there. Yeah, I'm already living
there, right? And and you and then you
bring this and you say, "Well, not so
fast." That's exactly one foot.
I thought that was very special. That's
great. Yeah. And I'm very committed to
it. This is a This is an example of
what, you know, what we're doing now,
right? Yes. Yes. So, the actual numbers
don't matter. You put in the third. I
put in the third. Good. Perfect. Right.
and and and and I think that you know
every person is different and I think
the beauty of of what I'm looking at our
work is that now being able to tailor
the game. Yeah. Yeah. And and we if what
happens, you know, is there's a few of
these that you're now fairly reliable
in, we ought to take them off the
display, you know, keep them in the
background. don't throw them out and add
some new things that are more
consistent, you know, even further
refined. What does it look like to be in
the new era? Absolutely. Yeah.
Absolutely. And so, uh, Allan, uh, you
know, we, this is a such a special I I
knew this was going to be a great
conversation. You know, one thing I want
to acknowledge for you, you know, just
about older and newer. I mean, let's
when you and I met,
you did not know the woman who you're
going to be marrying in 3 months or 4
months. She wasn't even on the scene,
you know, and you knew you wanted to be
in a committed relationship with the
right person. right now. You know how
many people spend decades in that place
of knowing they want to be with the
right person for the look how quickly
you did that and look how you know it
it's different you know we did a 360
right when you I we I interviewed the
people you worked with I bet you if I
interviewed the people you're working
with now they'd have you'd There'd be
some things that are still the same, but
it would be a radically different score
than what you did a year and a half ago.
I think we're going to take that. I'm
going to take on that challenge. Yeah, I
think we're going to do it. Yeah. I I
still have all the questions. We can do
the same questions and and and and check
it out. Absolutely.
Alan, I I really want to thank you for
what's to come. Yeah. Very good. I've
already thanked you for what we did when
we started this this conversation and
now I want to thank you for the the way
that we're going to work continue and in
the future and this is for Michael from
the future. I get it. No, I get it. And
and so you first you're well you're
welcome and second you know I'm I'm at
the stage of my life where you know so
in in the third act there are scenes
and and the scene that that I'm in right
now is giving away everything that I've
been fortunate enough blessed lucky
whatever word you want to worked hard to
get everything that I've been given, I
just want to give it away to people uh
who I respect and admire so that they
can take it to the next level. And
that's my legacy is how other people are
living their lives. And it I love
working with you. You're so hungry,
you're so open, and you're so fast.
It's it's fun. Thank you. Okay. Thank
you so much, Alan.